welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting these
webinars every Tuesday my name is
Carolyn you jerk and today I'll be
talking to you about how to start ml
projects you can ask questions anytime
on the platform and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them let's get started
so as I mentioned this presentation
today is around how to start machine
learning projects
it's called from hype to value machine
learning is a big buzzword these days
but how do you know if you're selecting
the right project that will justify your
investment will tell you more about how
to do that today so our discussion for
today is going to start around the ml
journey what it looks like what is that
typical path for companies like you then
we'll talk about use case identification
and qualification which is an important
step and making sure that you select a
feasible machine learning project we'll
walk through a few case studies and then
at the end we'll have more time for a
question and answer so first I want to
start by debunking a bit of a myth about
machine learning I often hear this from
customers so you have some data that's
your input you feed it into a machine
learning model that performs some magic
and then you get your answers or your
output that's not actually quite how it
works so when you think about machine
learning you can replace the word magic
with math so machine learning
fundamentally is using math to make
predictions so let's talk a little bit
more about exactly what machine learning
is the way I think about it is it's a
way to maximize the data you already
have and you're probably already using
it or at least collecting a lot of data
so think about machine learning in these
three steps you have a large quantity of
data you apply a mathematical algorithm
to that data and then you get a
forward-looking prediction that will
help you make a decision now I want you
to keep in mind these
steps as you think about how to apply
machine learning in your organization
sometimes the machine learnings not
always the best solution but when you're
making repeated decisions and you have
large quantity of data then it can often
be a really great way to get a
competitive advantage
so within Google Cloud we have a
professional services organization that
helps a lot of customers discover
feasible high-impact ml use cases for
their companies and we really think
about this as involving these three
important parts first is we want to work
closely with you and your domain experts
you know your business best and we're
basically here to guide you and this
presentation as well will hopefully
guide you as you're thinking about how
to start ml in your organization the
next step is feasible not magic so again
the fact that machine learning is magic
it's a bit of a myth so we really want
to help you qualify your machine
learning use cases and look at if
they're actually technically feasible
for your organization based on the data
that you have the last part involves
making sure that those use cases are
high-impact so looking at things like
what sort of revenue might be generated
by this machine learning use case or
what sort of cost savings can we expect
if we were to complete this machine
learning project so we think about the
machine learning lifecycle as having
these ten steps and it's an iterative
process today we're gonna really focus
on steps one and two but I'll walk you
through the end-to-end life cycle so you
have a sense of what comes after you've
defined those ml use cases so as I
mentioned today we're focusing on ml use
case identification and that's the best
place to start for machine learning
project you want to get very specific in
terms of what you're predicting and what
decisions are going to make so for
example if you're forecasting sales for
your stores you want to be sure about
exactly what you're predicting are you
predicting sales for each of your SKUs
every week
or four
next 12 weeks or for the next 52 weeks
so you need to get very specific in
terms of what you want to predict the
next step involves data exploration so
during this step your data analyst will
perform exploratory data analysis to
really understand your data what do you
have
is it good quality how can we link
together your different datasets so that
we can use them in the machine learning
project we'll also try to look at
relationships between the data as well
as any signals that might be missing and
how we might be able to bring in some
additional data sets so we can have
those signals and capture them in our
machine learning model step three is
around selecting an algorithm and this
often involves research in the problem
space that you're working in so for
example with that sales forecasting idea
you would want to do some review of what
are some other successful ml
applications related to sales
forecasting what sort of models are
people using and there's a lot wealth of
information out there that you can
really pull from so that you'll know
where to start after that you get into
your data pipeline and feature
engineering during this step is when you
really think about what are those inputs
that are going into our machine learning
model so when you think about those
inputs you'll want to consider again how
can you link them together into a single
record that will sort of feed into that
ml model you'll also want to think about
what are the components of that data
pipeline and we call those features so
again just think of those as the the
inputs to the ML model but you can get
creative around how you engineer those
features so for example you might look
at the previous week sales for that
sales forecasting use case but maybe
you'll also look at same source sales
from one year ago or maybe sales in that
geographic region two years ago this is
where you can also start to be creative
with your external data sets as well so
things like whether you could pull in
the average 10
sure from the week before or if there
were any inclement weather conditions
like a flood or a tornado that may
impact sales as well following that you
code your ml bottle so this is where
your ml engineer will come in and
actually create that machine learning
model that will be making the
predictions and often this is a very
iterative process and that's why you see
step six listed here you actually go
back and repeat you may tweak your data
pipeline and your features and then see
how your model performs and then you may
try it again
with some different features or you may
remove some of the features that you
thought were important but maybe they
aren't really improving your ml model so
again keep in mind that you're going to
iterate over and over again on your ml
model until you get some results that
you think are meaningful to you in your
business and that's what follows step
seven during this step it's important
for you to share those preliminary
results with your business stakeholders
so they can really see what you've
learned oftentimes will define specific
ml hypotheses during an ml project and
this is a really exciting part of the
project where you can share if you prove
those hypotheses with your business
stakeholders so for example maybe one of
your hypotheses were around weather has
an influence on our sales so at this
point you probably have some data that
you can show to prove or at least show
some preliminary findings related to
some of those hypotheses once you've
gotten to a level of success that meets
your business needs you can start to
plan for deployment and this step often
involves thinking about the end-to-end
business process that's affected by this
ml model so before we were just trying
to get those predictions right but now
we need to think about system
integrations so is this going to be part
of maybe a forecasting platform that you
use today does this need to be
integrated with some dashboards that
your executives look at so you'll need
to come up with a plan and the
requirements required for deployment
after that you actually operationalize
your model interpret
and google has a lot of tools to help
you do that and then you want to monitor
your model so over time your model
actually needs to be retrained you
actually need to continue to teach it
using new data because we all know your
business is going to continue to grow
and change so during the monitor phase
you'll want to come up with some
specific metrics that you look at so you
can determine when you want to do that
retraining or when you want to maybe
create a new ml model so monitoring
those metrics will be important to know
when should you start that retraining
process or when should you maybe start
development on another ml model so
that's the end-to-end machine learning
lifecycle again today we're going to be
focused on steps one and two but
hopefully this gives you a taste of what
the entire process looks like so now you
might be thinking ok this sounds great
but how do I do this who needs to be
involved well machine learning is really
a team sport
it doesn't just involve that ml engineer
that we talked about there's actually a
variety of players that you want to make
sure are engaged so these folks come
from different areas of your business
engineering analytics and science and
also domain experts so I'm going to talk
a little bit about some of the typical
roles that we see involved in these
machine learning projects and I want you
to think about who you might be able to
bring into these roles in your
organization so the first is your
project sponsor a decision maker this is
usually a leader that has some ownership
of the process that's going to be
impacted by ml someone who can really
come up with the success criteria for
the project and can also decide when
something might be ready to move into
production the next person is a domain
expert so this is usually someone who's
doing the process today and this is
someone who's really involved in perhaps
making a lot of human decisions around
the ml problem so for that sales
forecasting example it could be one of
your planners or one of your financial
analysts who's actually doing the
forecasting today and we'd want to
engage with that person understand how
are they making their decisions and how
can we try to get an m/l model to think
about the
in that way this is an interesting
opportunity to to get ahead of some
change management needs related to
adoption of ml so this domain expert is
gonna need to use this ml model down the
road and so engaging them from the
beginning really making the most of
their institutional knowledge will
hopefully make it easier for them once
you're actually deploying the model into
production and you're asking them to use
it the third role that's important to
consider is a data analyst so we talked
a lot about the importance of data we're
going to talk more about how you look at
it as you're qualifying your ml use case
this person will be involved in
assessing that data performing that
exploratory data analysis trying to
understand things like data quality
another role that's important to include
is the data engineer and this person's
really involved in creating that data
pipeline and again the pipeline is what
is ultimately going to feed into your
machine learning model a solution
architect is also another important role
for an ml project that person is going
to help you come up with your
overarching solution for deploying your
ml model you know I mentioned sometimes
there are some technical integrations
that are needed and that solution
architect would help define the
requirements and help to understand
those integrations so that you can have
a successful deployment and then the
last role to keep in mind is a project
manager so there's obviously a lot of
coordination involved across these
different roles and throughout the ml
lifecycle and you need a project manager
to help orchestrate all those different
activities now it's often great to think
about someone who has some experience in
more of an agile methodology because as
I mentioned before there's a lot of
iterations and repeating that occurs in
an ml project so you want someone who's
got that experience and knows how to
maintain that flexibility even as
they're trying to manage a more complex
project so I've
gonna focus on steps for use case
identification here's the way we think
about it with our clients so first we
want you to identify and prioritize your
top business challenges this will help
to ensure that your ml projects have the
greatest business impact so oftentimes
we'll get people together and it'll be a
mix of stakeholders and we'll have them
come up with those top business
challenges following that once you've
agreed on what those top business
challenges are we want you to brainstorm
and get creative around ml use cases
that address those top business
challenges so sometimes it's thinking
about what decisions we need to make
over and over again that could benefit
from predictions getting people together
and coming up with a large quantity of
ml use cases is a great way to do this
and then we often have people vote
collaboratively to decide where do we
think we should start and that voting
helps us to come up with a short list of
ml use cases that we really do some
deeper qualification around so normally
we look at about three to five use cases
that will hope to put on our ml roadmap
and step three involves qualifies those
use cases so we'll usually take a deeper
look at the data and we'll talk more
about what we do there to assess
technical feasibility it's also a good
practice to really quantify the business
impact of the ml use cases again so you
can make sure that you're justifying
your investment in the ml project after
that you can create your ml roadmap for
development and we'll talk a little bit
more about how to do that later on so as
you're starting to think about ml and
where to begin I want you to consider
where you are on this path to ml and
this path is really the journey that any
process or product might go through as
its maturing so I'm going to walk
through one example related to a contact
center or support team but you can think
about any process or product in the same
way so if you have a new contact center
at first you may receive requests from
customers and you may only have one
person answering the phone I know a lot
of startups begin this way
but over time as you get more and more
requests from customers you'll move out
of that individual contributor phase and
into the next step which is around
delegation you might need a team of
people to respond to those customer
support requests and that is phase two
of delegation during this phase there'll
be a lot of standardization that happens
of your business processes so that
anyone can actually perform that role
after that we often see customers move
into this digitization phase so this
will be where you'll maybe set up a
ticketing system to automate and help
digitize those support requests the
routing the solution and this is an
important step because it really
liberate and starts to collect a lot of
the data that in the past you maybe
weren't capturing in any sort of
meaningful way and over time as you
acquire more and more data you move into
this big data and analytics base and
sometimes you might stay in this phase
and that's okay but sometimes you may
want to do something more sophisticated
again especially when you're making
repeated decisions so you might want to
move into this machine learning phase so
with this contact center example you may
move into a phase where you start
automatically routing and predicting the
types of issues that customers have
based on their messages that they're
sending you so that's a very common use
case we see a lot of companies
implementing but in order to get there
you really have to make sure you're in
that big data and analytics space that
you're collecting that large volume of
data that really is required for any
machine learning project so again
consider where you are on this path to
ml and how mature your business process
or product might be as you're thinking
about ml projects I also think it's good
to be realistic about the effort that's
required it's a little bit different
than your traditional software
implementation projects so think about
these four activities that are involved
defining key performance indicators
collecting data building in
structure in optimizing your ml
algorithm so a question for you what
percent of time and effort do you think
each of these steps take so what we
often hear from customers is that their
expectation is very different than
reality so you can see here a lot of
people assume that optimizing the ml
algorithm that big green bar on top is
what really requires a lot of time and
effort but in practice that's actually
not true you can see the reality at the
bottom the dark blue area of collecting
data really takes quite a bit of time
for ml projects she should expect that
the other area that often takes a lot of
time with ml projects is building
infrastructure and that's represented by
that yellow bar at the bottom now google
cloud actually has done a lot of the
infrastructure building for you
so if you use some of our managed
services like cloud machine learning
engine will actually take care a lot of
a lot of that effort for you so keep in
mind this ml effort allocation as you're
thinking about your projects and as
you're doing your planning you're really
going to want to invest a lot of time in
that data collection and I think you'll
be surprised how little time is actually
spent on optimizing the specific ml
algorithm so as I mentioned before data
qualification is a really important step
as you're thinking about the feasibility
of your ml use cases so this is a list
of steps or a checklist that you can use
as you're thinking about ml use cases
and you're trying to assess their
feasibility as I'm walking through these
think about the data that you have to
support your ml use cases and how it
might measure up so the very first step
is around assessing the feasibility
based on any data ownership or practical
considerations so again machine learning
projects require large amounts of data
and you want to make sure that you have
ownership of that data so that you could
use it to build your ml model in many
cases that's not an issue
so for sales forecasting for example you
probably own a lot of that data yourself
if you're
you know managing the stores where the
sales are being made but sometimes there
are other scenarios where you don't own
the data and that can sometimes be a
blocker so it's important to think about
those practical considerations the next
step is around collecting samples so
once you've identified your ml use case
we want you to consider all of the data
that you currently collect that might be
used in an ml prediction so for the
sales forecasting example you may have
historical sales records from all of
your stores and you'll want to get a
sample of that data as you're assessing
the feasibility of that use case you may
also want to bring in other data sets
though things like promotional data that
have a really strong impact on the
problem as well so identify all those
different data sets and then collect the
samples you can then hand over those
samples to your data analyst who will
take a look at things like data quality
when I say data quality we're looking at
things like are there a lot of missing
values is there a lot of constant values
in the data set itself that can really
help us to understand if the data is
good quality or not you also want to
ensure you have labeled data and this
may be a new concept for some of you but
it's very critical for machine learning
projects so when I say labeled data you
want to have historical examples of what
you're trying to predict so for example
with sales forecasting you want those
historical sales records and if you're
trying to predict sales volume you need
to understand what that sales volume has
been in the past that data is used to
train the ml model to teach it so if you
don't have those labeled examples you
won't have a way to train your ml model
you also want to verify that your data
sets are large enough for model building
so one of the reasons why machine
learning is gaining so much steam these
days is because it has a lot to do with
all that big data that's being collected
in many different industries so you want
to make sure though that you have a
large enough volume to perform well in
these machine learning projects
generally the more data you have the
better but
when we're looking at some of these deep
learning algorithms the more complex
algorithms that are based on the way
your brain works we often look for data
points that are maybe in the hundreds of
thousands as a minimum to get started so
again you want to take a closer look at
the data you have and make sure that you
have a large enough volume of data and
lastly you want to check for class and
balance what is class imbalance well it
just means you need to have enough
positive and negative examples or enough
examples of different categories that
relate your machine learning problem so
for example I worked with one customer
that was trying to predict truck
breakdowns and we needed to have more
examples of trucks that had actually
broken down in the initial data set they
were collecting a lot of data points but
they only had 32 examples of trucks that
had broken down and that's an example of
that class imbalance you want to make
sure you have enough historical examples
of those trucks that are functioning
well as and the ones that have broken
down so again you can use this as a
checklist to think about how does your
data measure up for your machine
learning project so in this next slide
this is an example of an output that you
might have as you're going through this
use case identification process so on
the left you can see for use cases that
were identified so imagine we just had a
great workshop with different
stakeholders across the business and
from our tech organization and we came
up with these for use cases as a way of
solving our top business problem so
things like cross sell upsell customer
centric store layouts a recommendation
engine for online ordering and a chat
bot to support online orders so through
our qualification process we assess the
business impact and technical
feasibility of each use case and on the
right you see a nice visual summary of
that in this 2x2 matrix so you can see
here some of these use cases have a much
higher business impact like cross sell
upsell that definitely would have a nice
tie to increasing revenue but it's not
quite as feasible based on the data that
we looked at and the data that we're
collecting today so for our ml project
we may want to actually begin with use
case 3
for you still have a pretty high
business impact and they're much more
excusable so a recommendation engine for
online ordering or a chat bot to support
online orders could be two places where
we could start now I'm going to walk
through a few case studies that show you
how other businesses are applying
machine learning so Uniqlo is a Japanese
retailer that operates close to 2,000
stores all around the world and they
wanted to find ways to make their
customer shopping experience easier and
more enjoyable they looked at some of
their top business challenges and those
involved things like the changing retail
environment we all know that the way
that we make purchases and we shop is
really changing quite a bit and they
also wanted ways to bridge the offline
and online shopping experience Uniqlo
not only has many stores around the
world but they also have a pretty
awesome website where you can buy things
online but they didn't have a good way
to link those things so in terms of the
business impact they really saw some
pretty impressive results so they
created a chat bot that was integrated
with their mobile app and this chat bot
would provide answers to common customer
questions and these things ranged from
is this black sweater available in the
store that's nearest me to you know what
color skirts do you have available in
this style and they really saw a great
improvement in engagement as a result
from this chat bot so of the users that
had the app 40% of them interacted with
the chat bot on a weekly basis 40% so
that's pretty impressive in terms of
engagement numbers so when you think
about the chat bot there's also some
great tools that we have to accelerate
development and so there's a great
product available called dialogue flow
this is available through Google that
really can make building a chat bot
faster and easier so if this use case
interest you I would encourage you to
take a look at that
this next Kay
studies around sales forecasting so we
worked with a global consumer products
company and they were interested in
improving their sales forecasts from
their distributors to their retailers
and there were a few business challenges
that were identified that they were
hoping machine learning would help them
with so their existing process for
forecasting was very manual and it was
very clunky they were using a lot of
random spreadsheets to generate
forecasts they were also collecting
quite a bit of data across their
organization but they weren't really
using it so they knew that they could do
better if they found ways to harness
some of this data that they were
collecting today but they were really
only using a few data sets around
historical sales and things like
important holidays and events and
seasonality so they also felt they were
missing some really important signals
that were relevant to the problem so
they had a hunch that weather
for example was very important in terms
of driving sales of some of their
products but today they didn't really
incorporate that into their modeling so
we worked with them to create a custom
ML model and the model actually yielded
a 15% improvement in forecast accuracy
and it was projected to save them about
two million dollars so a pretty
significant business impact and this
model was interesting for them because
it incorporated quite a few
non-traditional data points like weather
demographic information and even Google
Trends information so machine learning
is a great way for you to think about
some of these external data sets that
might be relevant to your business
problem and really find ways to
incorporate them so this company for
example had been doing a lot of
statistical modeling and they were doing
some pretty sophisticated stuff but they
weren't able to incorporate some of
these other data points and with ml they
were able to do that so I'll walk
through so the top five tips that I have
for you before you start your ml project
so the first is around making sure your
use cases have a high business impact
again we want to make sure you get the
return on investment for your ml project
especially if you're just getting
started in this area so
really quantify the revenue and cost
savings associated with a specific ml
project get your hands around your data
to assess usability we walk through that
data checklist and it's very important
that you go through that for your ml
projects we also encourage you to get
samples of data so you can really take a
closer look at data quality and make
sure that the use case is feasible based
on all of that data that you're already
collecting number three is around being
clear about what decisions you'll make
with ml so remember back to the
beginning ml is all about making
predictions that can help you make
better business decisions so think about
what those decisions are what does that
process look like today and then how can
ml help make those business decisions
easier or better or more accurate once
you've done those things you should be
able to build a roadmap for ml and we
encourage you to start with quick wins
what we found is that over time you'll
adopt ml for one use case and then
you'll adopt it for maybe two or three
and that you'll have an acceleration of
using ml in your organization that's
actually what we've seen at Google over
time as we've done more and more ml
within our products but in order to get
started and really generate some results
we encourage you to start with quick
wins going through that process will
help you to establish a team establish a
model a way of working and also improve
the quality of your data for that use
case but even for another ml use case as
well and then finally the last thing
I'll leave you with is remember it's
math it's not magic so stay tuned for
our live Q&A we'll be back in about a
minute
all right so we've got some great
questions from our audience related to
starting ml projects so the first is how
is ml different than Big Data that's a
great question we talked a lot about how
it's important to really be at that Big
Data stage before you can move into an
ml project when you think about the
difference between ml and Big Data
remember ml is about making those
forward-looking predictions with Big
Data you're really looking at historical
information and you're performing
analysis based on those historical
trends so big data I like to think of
and associate with like a live real-time
dashboard where you're seeing exactly
what has just happened
but again machine learning is actually
all about thinking of forward-looking
predictions so for example big data
could tell you what your sales were and
trends in sales for the past month but
ml could tell you what do we believe the
sales will be for next month okay the
next question who needs to be involved
in defining ML use cases so this is
another really important point that I
want to make sure you understand so ml
use case definition is really a
cross-functional collaboration you need
to bring in people from your business
you need to bring in your data experts
you want to bring in your technology
leaders and your business sponsors so
you really want to make sure you have
that diverse team there's also that
brainstorming step that's involved with
defining the ml use cases and what we
find is when you have a more diverse
team you'll often come up with many more
ideas and better ideas at the end of
that brainstorming session so remember
you want to have that very diverse team
of folks across your organization and we
encourage you to think about Business
and Technology and also different levels
so everyone from you know maybe your
senior leaders your directors all the
way down to that data analyst who knows
the data really well and maybe is really
excited about machine learning
how much data do you need for an m/l
project so this is another good question
you know we talked a lot about how ml is
really powered by large quantities of
data and in general when we're thinking
about a deep learning algorithm a good
rule of thumb is to think about having
hundreds of thousands of data points as
a starting point now there are some
nuances to that that you may need to
consider for specific ML problems and
that's where an ml engineer can help as
you're thinking about those things but
again we think that large quantity of
data is important what we also find is
the more data you have the better your
ml model will perform so again if you
have some pretty high bars for your
performance of your ml model you really
do want to collect a lot of data as much
data it's possible that will really
improve that models performance okay and
the next question how do you assess the
business impact of an ml use case okay
so for this one you know we talked a
little bit about two important ways of
looking at the ml use case you want to
look at the impact on revenue so is
there a way that this ml use case might
substantially increase revenue or is
there a way that it will save costs that
you might have today so I would think
about those two things but in your
organization you may have some standard
way that you approach creating a
business case standard ways that you
approach creating a business case and ml
is not any different than other business
cases that you may have put together in
the past so you can also use any sort of
process or criteria that you may have in
your company today when you're building
business cases around other projects or
other investments so keep that in mind
as you're thinking about the business
impact of those ml use cases alright and
then the last question we have here is
what are some other examples of using
machine learning in retail okay this is
a really good one too
I think retail is a space where there's
a lot of ways that ml can really make a
big impact so a few big kind of
high-level categories to think
about are things like merchandising
supply chain pricing customer experience
as well as digital insights so when I
think about those five different areas
when we think about things like
merchandising
how does ml play a role there well you
can look at things like predicting
trends right that may affect the stock
that you want to have in your stores
supply chains another great area where
ml can make a big impact so you can
think about different places in your
supply chain where you might want to
make predictions that can optimize it so
everything from you know how do we want
to set our production sizes to what is
our minimum inventory level in the store
to how can we keep our shelves from
stocking out of items that are in high
demand I also mentioned the customer
experience there are a lot of ways that
ml can help there so you saw the one
example of a chat bot from Uniqlo but
you can think of other ways that ml can
improve the customer experience so
things like a recommendation engine you
know this is a really great quick win
for a lot of retail organizations so
looking maybe at your website and
looking at ways that you can recommend
products to customers based on the data
that you may have collected about their
shopping behavior in the past so the
last area mentioned was around the
digital experience in digital insights
and again for those online storefronts
that you might have you're probably
collecting a lot of data and you can
think about different ways you can
optimize that experience for your
customer as they're shopping and trying
to make those purchasing decisions all
right so I think that wraps up all of
our questions for today so stay tuned
for the next section session accelerate
cloud adoption using API management as
an abstraction layer
you